[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein kfz
rezept das gab es ist sehr lange nicht
mehr und ihr habt es euch gewünscht wir
machen leckere viel ehrgeiz und ich
zeige euch wie ihr sie ganz einfach zu
hause machen könnt die ganz genaue
mengenangaben stehen wie immer unten in
der
infobox genau ich starte jetzt in dem
ich erst mal mein hähnchenbrustfilet in
lange streifen schneiden und danach
mache ich direkt meinen teil tatsächlich
mein teig fertig denn ich mache so dass
ich in einen teig dunkel und später in
cornflakes dann welt für den teig nehme
ich mir zuallererst meine ich habe hier
eine große schüssel also eigentlich
werden einvernahme zutaten miteinander
verrührt ich starte mit dem mehl butter
milch dazu können auch buttermilch ganz
normale milch verwenden falls ihr die
grad nicht da hat und dann die eier dazu
die gewürze und etwas honig statt honig
könnt ihr auch agaven dicksaft zum
beispiel benutzen
[Musik]
so der teig ist jetzt schon fertig habe
einfach nur alles kurz zusammengerührt
und jetzt gebe ich meinem vorbereitetes
hähnchen einfach nur ein früher das gut
um und wenn dir zeit habt dann lasst es
gerne noch eine halbe stunde drin lassen
so ein bisschen marinieren wenn ihr
keine zeit habt könnt ihr auch sofort
weitermachen aber hatte ich noch gedacht
nehme ich mir die zeit das muss auf
jeden fall eine halbe stunde nicht hier
drin liegt sogar in den kühlschrank und
in der zwischenzeit habe ich mir gedacht
machen wir eine richtig leckere barbecue
sauce denn ich brauche mal irgendwas zum
dippen ich stehe für direkt am herd es
ist so easy gegeben alle zutaten in den
topf verändert und lassen es zehn
minuten köcheln die zutaten schreibe ich
euch auch natürlich in die infobox und
das ist eine barbecue sauce natürlich
auf basis von ketchup und zum ketchup
gebe ich ein bisschen rohrzucker ihr
könntet aufbauen zucker stattdessen
nehmen das macht auch noch mal diesen
karamell liegen geschmack da gebe ich
dann gewürze dazu chili paprikapulver
salz und pfeffer ein bisschen säure darf
nicht fehlen also anhand von meinem
apfelessig olivenöl kommen dazu und
orchester soße und ein roter soße okay
ich bin ehrlich ich weiß nicht wie man
es ausspricht schon mal kurz ich kann
nicht die einzige sein den ich weiß wie
man es ausspricht oder haben sagt guck
mal kriegst 100 punkte wenn du weißt wie
man das ausspricht ich hab das jetzt
bekomme ich das ausgesprochen was und
ich habe gedacht wenn ich so auf spricht
er wird es noch schlimmer als befürchtet
ist wir machen so jetzt kommt erstmal
eine einwendung wie man es wirklich
ausspricht ist es soll einfach
rochester
rochester chinas
gastauftritten ja gerne süß so viel spaß
und
und das cool
[Musik]
so zehn minuten lang durfte das ganze
zweimal köcheln und jetzt ist die
barbecue soße auch schon fertig ging so
schnell es gibt jetzt hier noch ein glas
macht es zu könnt ihr euch übrigens
waren genießen damit auch sehr gut ich
will die rest jetzt noch mit meinem
touch heraus und an den im nächsten
schritt einfach cornflakes richtig schön
aggressionen rauslassen das mache ich am
besten mit dann gefriert hüte
[Musik]
so meine station habe ich mir aufgebaut
ich habe auch schon das fett erhitzt
dann braucht ihr frittierfett ich es bei
mir in der hochrhein pfanne das hat so
ungefähr 78 minuten bei stufe 8 gedauert
und ein kleiner tipp von mir wenn ihr
wissen wollt ob das fällt jetzt auf
temperatur ist und ihr kein thermometer
habt dann nehmt euch einfach einen
schaschlikspieß gibt es dann in das öl
rein und werden die bläschen langsam
aufsteigen dann ist es richtig wenn sie
super schnell aufsteigen dann ist es
wahrscheinlich schon zu heiß und noch
ein tipp von mir falls ihr einen
schaschlikspieß jetzt immer und immer
wieder verwendet dann kann es sein dass
es durch das fett in dass wir das halt
die ganze zeit eingetrübt habe das
einfach keine reaktion mehr zeigt dann
nehmt ihr euch einfach ein neues und
könnte checken ob die blasen dann hoch
steigen oder nicht meine fahne meine
töpfe die speichern halt die wärme sehr
stark deshalb gehe ich jetzt auch schon
wieder runter von stufe 8 auf 6 das
heißt da auch immer wieder so ein
bisschen einpendeln und jetzt können wir
schon als panin und frittieren gehen
dafür nehme ich mir jetzt immer meine
hähnchen streifen gibt die in die
cornflakes panade hab übrigens komplex
genommen die nicht zusätzlich noch einen
zuckerzusatz haben da könnt ihr auch
gerne darauf achten und dann kommen sie
einfach ins frittierfett
[Musik]
wir machen diese
erschöpft nach wirklich also ich bin
echt super gespannt was der hammer sagt
mein größter kritiker alle denken immer
du sagst ja lecker lecker aber ein
weites haben soll wirklich der größte
kritiker ja ich würde sagen sie sehen
aus wie christie's ich sagen ja sie kann
okay
das gleiche also es sieht aus wie crispy
chicken und nicht wie viel lieber smsen
und
großen ja das gleiche rennen ich bin ja
auch die jusos auch selbst gemacht
das gehört
mir schmeckt hälftig nicht selber loben
aber scheint echt krass wenn man ehrlich
also ich war ich kenne die antwort aber
man muss es einfach noch erwähnen ohne
jetzt arrogant rüber zu kommen besser
gehts wieder das
sechseinhalb stunden später wir lernen
überlegt
wie es heißt wie schnell das gegentor
nicht wirklich über krebs über kiedrich
us-wirtschaft frittiert ich hab dann
abtropfen dazu das was hast du mir so
eine frische filme hand wissen ja und
total zahlt auch das helfen das total
sagt leute macht das nach ganz es geht
ruckzuck überhaupt wenig zutaten ihr
braucht bin 0 equipment dafür günstig
und es ist günstig und ich glaube
ihr habt ja ein richtig hähnchenfleisch
drin und wenn wir da noch auf die gute
qualität achtet dann kann man ja ohne
gewissen
also ich kann mir das jetzt noch mal so
richtig gezielt vom fernsehen war
ja okay okay als leiter ich höre als
klar so ich wollte doch ganz gefallen
mir verabschiedet das sind die die ich
ohne panade macht gemacht und ich wollte
einfach mal ausprobieren wie sieht's aus
ohne ohne kontext panade ich finds mit
complex 1000 mal besser
ja also es sind so auch gewürze drin und
so weiter aber das knackige fehlt an
einem fahrrad ist auch okay also jetzt
probiert ist okay also ganz viel freude
im namen machen abonniert den kanal
kostenlos weil sie das noch nicht schon
längst getan habt und dann sehen wir uns
auch beim nächsten rezept also und
schreibe mir eure nächsten gsi
vorschläge unten in die kommentare
verabschieden uns
[Musik]